il ya plein de choses qui m'échappent je
maîtrise pas je le dis avec sincérité et
que deuxièmement ils ont fait les choses
bien et des choses moins bien que ça
c'est sûr mais quand je vois ces débats
là depuis un an entre les médecins
d'accord en soit nous on est des noms ça
change on est au milieu et on nous
manipule et à gauche et à droite et on
sait plus est par contre vous avez la
vérité est là la vérité non mais vous
êtes à même de nous mentir ou mais ça ça
me gêne c'est fâcheux c'est un débat
politique c'est que l'opposition macro
is you go thomas crown j'ai jamais vu un
mec on parlait karim a raison de dire
il a été courageux de dire je rencontre
finit par le président de la république
encourage ses parts en tête du 1e mai de
l'opposition dieu mais bravo président
je vous entends pour vous mais je vous
trouve courageux on peut pas en être
certain le faire un nom est toujours
officiellement passe aujourd'hui c'est
de la bouche et après vous voulez vous
attendez jarre et du miel dans la bouche
en cours maintenon non mais moi j'ai pas
de fiel trois qualifiés chaque fois que
tu parles je vais pas enfin que tu
parles quand je vous dit je vais te
souviens tu fais tu fais 2,5 pour cent
d'accord si nous présentons des grands
jours juste une phrase mais jamais rompu
bernard cet accord avec touches sur le
plateau pour la vaccination
interrogation pourquoi ça va plus vite
on est tous d'accord là dessus
c'est clair net et précis je réponds
dehors j'en déduis que voulez vous faire
vacciner en arabe
bernard vous allez vous faire vacciner
sur son 16e jérôme est ensuite florina
peut-être aussi bref
parce qu'au final cette crise est mal
gérée parce que ce sont des décisions de
politique politicienne
non pas des décisions de politique
humaine des poneys des dépositions des
politiques à responsabilisation des
politiques de pédagogie je l'avais déjà
dit la semaine dernière un moment donné
au lieu de faire chier les gens ou les
empêcher de vivre au lieu de les
empêcher de manifester au lieu de les
empêcher de travailler tout soyons
responsables les uns autant que les
autres soyons pédagogue
mettons fin à la répression et arrêtons
tous ces mensonges et tu ces chiffres
parce qu'en tant que ça à 8 millions par
6 10 millions par là et ceci par ci et
ça va non stop
aujourd'hui il ya de l'humain d'accord
il ya des gens qui souffrent en france
il ya de plus en plus de suicider
il ya de plus en plus de gens qui pètent
des câbles il ya de plus en plus le plus
en plus en gens qui tombent dans la
misère et ça on en secondes noces donc
vous êtes d'accord pour ne pas confinés
comme la dessine en gelée n'a rien donné
on parle si la crise a été bien gérée
moi je dis que non parce que au final on
a imposé les choses en français à défaut
de les responsabiliser de mettre en
place de la pédagogie pour que puisse se
gérer gérard parce que les accords qu'il
a eu raison de ne pas continuer
moi non parce que c'est la deuxième
quand on vous pose la question des ondes
n'a pas confiné là il a eu raison de ne
pas confiné parce que forcément je vais
dans son sens ne suis pas pour le tout
finement en mai 2 de sa bouche à lui sur
sa prise de décision unilatérale sur son
conseil de défense c'est de la politique
politicienne pour derrière vous pour
avoir sauf qu'aujourd'hui une salle
dumas il ya des gens qui meurent on
n'est pas là pour faire un lien si
j'avais confiance